[Musica]
io questa sera da medico vi parlerò di
un malato ma questo malato non è una
persona questo malato si chiama Servizio
Sanitario
Nazionale un servizio sanitario
nazionale che nasce il 23 dicembre del
1978 con la legge istitutiva 833
fortemente voluta di fatto da tutte le
forze politiche e con la grande spinta
di Tin Anselmi che avete visto qualche
settimana fa in una fiction televisiva
però
riparto da quasi 30 anni prima dal 22
dicembre del 1900
quando di fatto venne approvata la
costituzione italiana che all'articolo
32 riporta La Repubblica tutela la
salute come diritto fondamentale
dell'individuo e interesse della
collettività mi permetto di sottolineare
questo aspetto nella costituzione sono
credo 13 diritti fondamentali ma solo
per il diritto alla tutela della salute
viene utilizzato l'aggettivo
fondamentale quindi i padri costituenti
Probabilmente con questa eccezione che
conferma la regola avranno voluto dirci
qualche cosa e dicevo abbiamo dovuto
aspettare praticamente quasi 30 anni per
avere un'infrastruttura il Servizio
Sanitario Nazionale che con tutte quelle
che sono le
sue ospedali l'assistenza primaria tutte
le attività di prevenzione si prende
cura nelle attività di prevenzione
diagnosi cura terapia riabilitazione
fino alle cure palliative e credo che il
Servizio Sanitario Nazionale rappresenti
una conquista sociale irrinunciabile per
tutte le persone ecco attenzione È
importante anche quello che c'è scritto
in costituzione si parla di individui
non si parla di cittadini quindi
indipendentemente dal colore della pelle
da dove vengono o cioè il nostro
servizio sanitario nazionale sostenuto
dalla fiscalità generale Di fatto si era
posto l'obiettivo di curare tutti
indipendentemente da variabili
individuali quale il sesso l'età la
residenza anche la razza l'etnia della
persona oggi però che cosa stiamo
vedendo anzi che cosa state vedendo voi
come utenti pazienti del servizio
sanitario nazionale un'infrastruttura
con la quale tutti noi in in qualunque
momento della vita sicuramente o abbiamo
dovuto o dovremmo avere avere a che fare
Sol solo per quelle che sono un po'
tutte le attività di
prevenzione i principi fondanti del
Servizio Sanitario Nazionale sono tre
sono l'universalità sono l'equità e sono
l'uguaglianza e oggi mi sento di dire da
analista attento del sistema visto che
ecco nel 2013 lanciamo con la fondazione
gimbe la campagna Salviamo il nostro
servizio sanitario nazionale che queste
parole oggi questi principi fondanti
sono state sostituite da altre parole
chiavi che troneggiano sui media sui
social
media in TV sui giornali un po' ovunque
infinite lista d'attesa 2 anni per una
mammografia nel pubblico un anno per
un'ecografia piuttosto che per una
risonanza magn ea tempi inaccettabili
Cosa fa la gente se i soldi va il
privato e quindi altro effetto
collaterale aumenta la spesa privata
auto Pocket la chiamano gli esperti se
non hanno i soldi rinunciano alle cure
l'Istat ci dice che nel 2021 l'anno
peggiore in assoluto
l'1,1 della popolazione italiana ha
rinunciato ad almeno una prestazione
sanitaria credo che sia un dato di
particolare rilievo Visto che stiamo
parlando di circa 6 milioni di persone
che succede Quali sono le altre parole
chiave l'ha mancato accesso
all'innovazione Noi oggi abbiamo delle
conquiste straordinarie della ricerca
clinica ma non riusciamo a metterli a
disposizione di tutti e vi ricordo che
la qualità dell'assistenza sanitaria non
è avere i centri di eccellenza Ma fare
in modo che la qualità dell'assistenza
sia equa e omogenea Per tutte le persone
in particolare per quelle più anziane
quelle più fragili quello quelle meno
abbienti ma in generale il principio di
equità quello di uguaglianza e quello di
universalismo oggi sono stati
sostanzialmente traditi il fenomeno
della migrazione sanitaria Nel 2020
circa 3 miliardi e 300 milioni di euro
si sono spostati prevalentemente dal sud
al nord le diseguaglianze diseguaglianze
regionali all'interno della stessa
regione tra aree metropolitane aree
rurali tra diverse fasce socioeconomiche
della popolazione anche tra uomini e
donne quindi una situazione che oggi
viene vissuta sulla pelle dei cittadini
in particolare delle persone
che spesso non riescono nemmeno a
curarsi per l'impossibilità a farlo ma
che sulla carta è tutelata dall'articolo
32 della Costituzione è da quella che
dovrebbe essere una leale collaborazione
governo regione che concretizza il
concetto più alto di Repubblica ma che
in realtà non avviene Ecco che allora
oggi Stasera vi volevo raccontare un po'
la nostra diagnosi clinica di questo
malato che abbiamo definito un malato
con multimorbid molti voi sapranno Cosa
significa questa questa parola
significa un paziente che ha
generalmente anziano 70 anni 75 anni
anche se il Servizio Sanitario Nazionale
Ne ha poco più di 40 che ha diverse
patologie magari c'è il diabete ha lo
scompenso cardiaco ha problemi
articolari Comincia ad avere qualche
difficoltà cognitiva magari anche
problemi sociali vive da solo Ecco il
Servizio Sanitario Nazionale oggi dovete
immaginarlo come un paziente con multim
morbidità che vive per altro in un
ambiente e sapete quanto i fattori
ambientali condizionano la salute che
non è particolarmente salubre vi
racconto brevemente le quattro malattie
la prima malattia da cui affetto il
Servizio Sanitario Nazionale è il
definanziamento
pubblico Noi abbiamo stimato che negli
anni
2010-2019 sono cambiati i governi di
tutti i colori al servizio sanitario
nazionale sono stati sottratti circa 37
miliardi di euro la grossa botta fu data
diciamo dal governo tecnico Monti per
risanare la finanza pubblica circa 25
miliardi degli altri 12 sono stati un
po' effetto dei Def finanziamenti
durante il diciamo il triplet Letta
Renzi e poi Gentiloni
37 miliardi in meno capite bene che sono
una cifra importante una cifra che si è
abbattuta prevalentemente sul personale
Ecco oggi si sente dire non ci sono i
medici Non ci sono gli infermieri non si
trovano gli anestesisti non ci sono i
medici al pronto soccorso Ma perché
Perché a causa di questo taglio di fatto
è stato imposto il tetto alla spesa del
personale quindi le regioni non possono
assumere personale nuovo sono stati
bloccati i contratti che hanno
ovviamente eh stabilizzato gli stipendi
hanno progressivamente demotivato il
personale sanitario sono state
finanziate poche borse di studio per le
scuole di specializzazione Quindi quando
oggi si sente dire mancano i medici
particolarmente in alcune specialità
mancano gli infermieri non è che è un
problema che è nato stamattina è nato 15
anni fa e nessun governo di fatto ha mai
effettuato rilanci del finanziamento
pubblico c'è stato poi durante il
periodo covid un bel salto in alto del
fabbisogno sanitario nazionale cioè di
qu quel fondo che di fatto viene
ripartito alle regioni ma non è stato un
investimento per la struttura del
Servizio Sanitario Nazionale è stata per
fronteggiare l'emergenza e nonostante
questo investimento le regioni si
trovano quasi con 5 miliardi 800 milioni
di buco quando diciamo si era finalmente
riallineato la grande voragine economica
della
sanità la seconda patologia è quella
della dei livelli essenziali di
assistenza Che cosa sono sono tutte le
prestazioni che stanno incluse nei
diritti che tutti i cittadini possono
esigere perché stanno in degli elenchi
l'ultimo aggiornamento è avvenuto nel
2017 e questi elenchi dovrebbero essere
continuamente aggiornate a seguito delle
innovazioni che la ricerca e la scienza
ci mettono a disposizione però capite
bene che quando nel 2017 fu espanso
questo paniere dei livelli essenziale
assistenza che in pratica si significa
espandere il numero delle e la quantità
e la qualità delle prestazioni che
possono essere richieste dai cittadini e
prescritte dai professionisti sanitari
se nello stesso momento che tu espandi
il paniere e Riduci le risorse è
evidente che non è possibile che queste
prestazioni vengono erogate e accanto al
mancato aggiornamento a partire dal 2017
quindi oggi Molte innovazioni non le
possiamo non le possiamo esigere oggi in
Italia perché non sono incluse in questi
famosi elenchi abbiamo una situazione
estremamente eterogenea cioè
l'esigibilità dei Lea avviene in maniera
possiamo dire adeguata al nord avviene
in maniera parziale al centro e avviene
in maniera disastrosa al sud con
percentuali di adempimento sono delle
pagelle che il min con cui il Ministero
Battezza diciamo dai voti alle regioni
che raggiungono il 92 93% per l'Emilia
Romagna il Veneto la Lombardia Ma che di
fatto nei primi 10 in classifica vedono
come uniche due regioni del centro
l'Umbria e le marche il centro sud
sostanzialmente sta tutto tutto nella
parte bassa della classifica con
ulteriore grave conseguenza che quando
si hanno voti troppo bassi poi un po'
come a scuola si viene rimandati ci sono
i cosiddetti piani di rientro che sono
un po' dei meccanismi di
commissariamento dello Stato sarebbero
di affiancamento tecnicamente alle
regioni che non erogano le prestazioni
sanitarie cittadini ma che hanno avuto
in questi anni come unico obiettivo
quello del riequilibrio finanziario
delle regioni senza consentire uno
sviluppo per cui oggi rispetto a 10 anni
fa il il GAP nord e sud si è ampliato in
maniera importante e adesso che abbiamo
i soldi del pnrr che dovrebbero in
qualche maniera colmare le
diseguaglianze territoriali Ci si
inventa un
po' il regionalismo differenziato
un'altra
diciamo modalità con la quale le
diseguaglianze inevitabilmente saranno
acuite tra nord e sud altra patologia
gli sprechi e le inefficienze non
pensiamo che i circa 130 miliardi di
spesa pubblica siano spese sempre e
comunque in maniera Ecco un termine
tecnico appropriata ci sono tante
prestazioni inutili sia prescritta dai
professionisti devo dire anche richieste
dai pazienti è quello che gli inglesi
chiamano overuse cioè eccesso di
prestazione sanitaria Troppi esami
inutili che in quel momento non cambiano
nulla rispetto al monitoraggio della
malattia ma anche tanti farmaci che
vengono presi sostanzialmente senza
nessuna motivazione Ecco sappiate che in
molte scuole non in Italia sono nati i
corsi per la De prescription cioè gli
anziani quando prendono avendo 7 8 10
patologie e devono prendere 25 30
tipologie di farmaci al giorno 2530
compressi al giorno di diverse tipologie
di farmaci hanno due problemi riducono
la compliance e aumentano gli effetti
avversi quindi una nuova scienza si sta
sviluppando cosa tolgo A quel paziente
anziano per fare in modo che lui prenda
soltanto quei farmaci che Gli permettono
di migliorare il suo stato di salute Poi
ci sono tante frodi e tanti abusi sapete
quante volte anche agli onori della
cronaca vengono fuori eh appalti
truccati eh situazioni particolarmente
critiche che poi ovviamente sono oggetto
anche di di azione della magistratura
poi sono delle cose strane quelle che io
Noi abbiamo classificato e chiamato gli
acquisti a costi eccessivi cioè la
protesi eh dell'anca piuttosto che la
valvola cardiaca che da una regione
all'altra può costare anche 10-15 volte
in più avrete sentito sicuramente
l'esempio della siringa Ma la siringa
costa poco quando noi parliamo di
valvole parliamo di prodotti che hanno
un costo anche di 10-1000 nella regione
che costa meno e poi ci sono situazioni
di grande complessità amministrativa
Perché usiamo poco l'informatica abbiamo
un apparato burocratico
straordinariamente ipertrofico e poi
tutto quello che rientra un po' l'altra
malattia nel coordinamento inadeguato
tra quello che è il mondo ospedaliero e
il mondo dell'assistenza territoriale o
delle cure primarie che continuano
Purtroppo a rimanere Due Mondi di che si
parlano poco e che spesso si fanno anche
diciamo delle battaglie delle lotte
senza quartieri accanto a queste
patologie poi vi dicevo C'è un po'
quello che è l'ambiente e l'ambiente ha
due problemi
e la Repubblica quella che c'è scritto
nell'articolo 32 della Costituzione oggi
secondo l'articolo 117 da chi è
rappresentata dal governo e dalle
regioni Ognuno dei quali ha i suoi
compiti il governo definisce lo Stato
definisce i livelli essenziale
assistenza e mette le risorse il le
regioni organizzano l'assistenza
sanitaria e la leale collaborazione tra
governo e regioni è proprio
quell'elemento che dovrebbe garantire la
tutela della salute ma questa leale
collaborazione spesso si trasforma in
conflitto istituzionale e secondo voi su
chi si scarica questo conflitto
istituzionale se non Sulle fasce più
fragili e più deboli della popolazione e
ultimo ma non meno importante le
aspettative dei cittadini e pazienti
cittadini e pazienti che purtroppo oggi
anche per l' eccesso di informazione per
l'infodemia che viviamo sono po'
diventati anche consumatori di servizi e
prestazioni sanitarie quindi non è non
esprimono una domanda di salute ma
esprimono la domanda di una singola
prestazione e non è quella che ci dà la
salute perché la salute significa presa
in carico significa offerta di servizi
in rete significa integrazione ospedale
territorio tutto questo per dire che
cosa che gli analisti ormai un po' tutti
sia noi come fondazione gimbe ma anche
tanti altri Abbiamo fatto la diagnosi e
conosciamo anche la terapia la terapia è
fatta di rilancio del finanziamento
pubblico è fatta di definizione di un
adeguato perimetro dei livelli
essenziali di assistenza che sia
proporzionale a quello che è il
finanziamento è fatto di rilancio delle
politiche del personale sanitario che
continuano a essere ringraziati ancora
oggi con la retorica degli eroi e sono
quelli che ci hanno un po' tirato le
castagne dal fuoco per quanto hanno
potuto da una situazione così tragica
come quella della pandemia Va rivista
l'organizzazione dei servizi sanitari
perché in questo momento non è adeguata
voglio dire con in questa frammentazione
che esiste tra ospedale e territorio e
tante altre cose che abbiamo descritto
in quello che abbiamo chiamato il piano
di rilancio del Servizio Sanitario
Nazionale però ecco e arrivo alla
conclusione del mio intervento o
richiamando il concetto di scelta che è
un po' la parola chiave di questa serata
servono coraggiose scelte politiche Cioè
è arrivato un momento in cui la politica
ma non il governo attuale la politica
nel senso più ampio del termine più alto
del termine quella che forse non abbiamo
da tanti anni Bisogna decidere che cosa
fare di questo servizio sanitario
nazionale Bisogna decidere quale sanità
pubblica vogliamo lasciare in eredità
alle future generazioni perché se quella
che è ancora scritta nella legge
istitutiva del 1978 bisogna prendere una
strada rifinanziare adeguatamente e
progressivamente il Fondo Sanitario
Nazionale e fare una serie di riforme
coraggiose che permettono di rilanciarlo
nel 2023 e negli anni a venire tenendo
conto della transizione demografica di
quella tecnologica e di quella
epidemiologica cioè il mondo è cambiato
il Servizio Sanitario Nazionale per
tante cose è rimasto diciamo negli anni
90 Se invece si decide che non possiamo
spendere più del 6,1 6,2% del PIL per
per la sanità pubblica è evidente che
bisogna prendere delle altre strade come
hanno fatto altri paesi aprire la logica
del del libero mercato far entrare il
mondo delle assicurazioni come lo St sta
lo sta già facendo in maniera subito le
strisciante ma farlo entrare in maniera
regolamentata non c'è nulla di male per
una per per la politica dire la sanità
pubblica non ce la possiamo più più
mantenere più permettere rispetto a
quella che è la nostra finanza pubblica
con un debito pubblico tra più alti di
Europa e con un'evasione fiscale che
raggiunge cifre mostre di qualcuno dice
90 Qualcuno dice 110 miliardi l'anno è
una scelta politica e ci vuole coraggio
a fare questa scelta Ma ci vuole anche
coraggio a fare le riforme adeguate per
andare nell'una o nell'altra direzione
perché credo che non sia accettabile
scaricare sui cittadini e sulle loro
tasche quelli che sono degli errori
politici di programmazione sanitaria e
di mancato finanziamento perché la
salute è tutelata dall'articolo 32 della
Costituzione e Permettetemi una battuta
finale la sanità pubblica o se preferite
il Servizio Sanitario Nazionale è come è
proprio come la salute ti accorgi che
esiste quando l'hai perduta e quando nel
2013 noi lanciammo il programma
Programma istituzionale gimbe Salviamo
il Servizio Sanitario Nazionale io dissi
Sì Guardate che la fine del Servizio
Sanitario Nazionale non sarà annunciata
dal fragore di una valanga ma dal lento
e silenzioso scivolamento di un
ghiacciaio di grandi dimensioni che
richiede lustri che richiede decenni
forse anche un ventennio e di fatto oggi
si comincia a toccare con mano quella
perdita del Servizio Sanitario Nazionale
che oggi ciascuno di noi tocca con mano
e soprattutto Lede i diritti civili di
tutte le persone
Grazie
i